and yeah so how did we do the whole
thing because now we know what we use
but we don't really know how to attack a
coffee machine so neither me nor my
flatmate are electrical engineers I did
like two semesters in university but
like most of the people here probably if
you didn't do a topic for years you tend
to forget everything or most of it as
you will see throughout the process that
I clearly forgot a lot and so we did
what most people would do when they when
they figure something out that they have
no clue about we just opened this thing
so we took out all the screws that were
there literally all the screws initially
that were like from the casing so we
took all sides out even though we were
only interested on this side and there
were a couple of things here that were
of interest for us and they were all in
that corner um so the whole machine can
be controlled it has a major power
switch on the back but all the other
controls are on the right side of the
coffee machine and our buttons so we
have the buttons here and then we have a
micro controller that does the actual
work and we have this interesting cable
that connects the two and it was
interesting because it was an actual
cable they weren't soldered together or
something was like a pretty big cable
that we could just unplug so we did that
and we just took out the whole thing and
this is what we ended up with so this is
the actual control panel of the button
and it allows you to basically have
eight pins down there that's where the
cable plugged in and then you have seven
LEDs that are on the one hand used to
show state but they also use for error
messages etc and then you have those six
buttons so the bottom right one is the
important one that's power
the top one top right one is espresso
and the top and the right one in the
middle is is a normal coffee the left
ones are for for milk coffees etc also
we didn't we didn't focus on them
initially and this is the interesting
table unfortunately didn't have a
picture of the original setup so this
would be actually the picture of the
final setup that's where that's why we
have nice tape around it but basically
what we did is we took one side of the
cable
we just jammed in a bunch of jumper
wires so we could connect that to to the
temple or later into the into a
breadboard and then we we sat down and
thought about what do we actually know
about this board so we have eight cables
or eight pins that we want to control we
have six switches and we have seven LEDs
now the idea that we had was well we
have a cable so we can connect this to
the tehsil and we can figure out what
protocol is being spoken between this
control plate and the microprocessor we
can spoof this and then just let the
tehsil sent this protocol so basically
what our idea was is that we have power
going in from one pin and then we have
at least three pins that must represent
the buttons because say we have six pins
or six buttons we could use like a
binary flag and just represented with
three pins and then we have three pins
to control the LEDs but what is the
eighth cable for because our math
doesn't really add up here
but we figured let's let's go for the
assumptions and try naive approach so
this is the script to control the castle
using johnny-five
so we import the johnny-five library and
then we are import the tesla Isle plugin
so that allows us to communicate with
the johnny-five library and the tehsil
and then once the board is ready we just
create seven pins we admit omitted the
one that we connected to five poles
because 3.3 volts didn't lit up the LEDs
5 volts did so you can see how
scientifically we approach this whole
thing and then we set them to analog
mode so the idea was can we figure out
if the analog mode measures the voltage
on the pin so we could see if there is a
voltage difference when we press a
button for example and then we injected
them in the repple because journey 5 has
a nice rattle so when we start off the
script we can interact with that so we
just measured the values and
unfortunately analog pins are very good
and fluctuating so we couldn't get a
proper value out of this so we had to
you tweak this slightly and take out
this analog mode and turn it into a
digital pin so the difference is you can
only set a digital pin to high or low
and you can only read high or low so
it's 1 or 0 and we did that and we
figure it out so when we just plug in
power we have the three of the right
LEDs glowing up so that's good that part
seems to be power and if we turn off
three of the pins we can actually turn
off these three LEDs all the other ones
didn't work we we literally wrote a
binary flag that went through all
combinations but we couldn't get them on
but we knew that when you four pins now
we knew one is power and three can
control the LEDs so we're getting close
to our our initial assumption so what we
did with the other four pins was we
declared them as button so johnny-five
has a has a button clasp in it that
allows us to really use the power of
JavaScript by having our event listeners
on press and release so this is where
javascript is really cool for hardware
hacking because we can say listen for
whenever a button is pressed or when
it's released and it's just way easier
than writing a loop and figuring out of
the value changed and we did this and it
was some notes that we took in the
meantime and I could go through them but
they all don't mean anything but we were
onto something because we knew that pin
one was power 4 2 5 and 7 the LEDs were
able we were able to control through
pins 4 to 6 but the weird part was 7 & 8
were the only ones reacting on buttons
so whenever we press the bottom right
one
they were triggering 7 & 8 respectively
when we press the top two ones they
progressive and eight and if we set if
it helped set one bit to high we would
be able to trigger the other two as well
so we could use pin 2 & 3 to turn off
the buttons left and right but that's
not what we wanted right we want to be
able to figure out if that button was
but we could just figure out if one of
three of if one of three buttons has
been pressed which meant that that was
pretty useless so we had to go back to
the drawing board quite literally so we
took a picture of this for the first
time because I mean the plate is like
this big
and we're like looking at it like this
the whole time so we figured maybe
taking a picture is a bit more
productive so we took a picture zoomed
into it and then use the software called
Fritzing that you can use to create
diagrams and we turned this into this
beautiful diagram and it looks like a
mess and it is a mess because what we
did is we assumed into the picture and I
went to said okay I'm going to go from
this pin to this pin because they might
be connected and then my flatmates used
a multimeter to measure the resistance
between these two parts and if the
resistance is zero that means the two
pins are connected our approach meant
that we had to go from resistor to
resistor as well so that's what we left
out all the resistors on this thing or
what we deemed were resistors and while
this looks like a mess this was way more
useful for us because we could finally
figure out that not only pour a pin one
was power but pin two and three were
power as well and that was the reason
why the other LEDs never laid on because
we had to put five volts on this pin in
order to actually see that this that
these LEDs light up and the process of
figuring this out we'd burn two of the
LEDs though so by figuring out hey what
if we connect five volts directly to
this LED we that was I'd like 4 a.m. so
we were slightly slightly tired so we
broke two but in the end all of them
that were still working lit up so that
was a good approach but the switches
still showed the same problem we knew
that 1 2 3 R power 4 to 6 or LEDs so we
were able to finally flick on the
different LEDs but 7 to 8 we're still
the only ones that react to buttons
and we can't figure out which button was
pressed by just having two bit and so we
realized that three of these things
aren't LEDs does anyone have an idea
what this is
I mean it's written there but does
anyone know what it diet is alright one
person so diets are a few people so
diets are similar to LEDs they have one
property which is the current can only
flow into one direction to be and the
other directions blocked so an LED does
that and light up light up but diet will
just control the current going only in
one direction so we drop the LEDs from
the diagram and we added the three diets
and suddenly stuff made more sense we
could because we could follow the power
and we could see where it went and this
was super useful because we finally
figured out that there was a mapping and
the mapping was ATS which one was
connected between P 3 and P 7 switch to
was P 3 to P 8 and you see that all of
them are connected ultimately to seven
or eight so that that finally explained
why we you could only listen to the two
it gave us the same gave up a problem
though that all of these switches were
dependent on the input as well and that
meant we can fake the protocol we can
just send in high low high low to tell
it what button was pressed but we had a
useful thing at home that we've bought
kind of in luckily right before the
attack and those were relays
so relays are digital switches like
electronic switches that you can use for
example microcontroller like the tehsil
to flick them rather than having to
press them so what we did is we wired
the cable from the coffee machine into a
breadboard and then from there we
reconstructed the same setup that we had
here on just with the relays instead so
we only had four relate so we decided to
map only the three right buttons and
left out the left left three and we also
wired up these LEDs to these three LEDs
to show up which status it is in so that
we know whether the coffee machine is
heating right now
etc so this was the initial wire up we
had to be very careful to not touch the
hot coffee machine while testing it even
though my flatmate I think brewing
himself twice and then we scripted a
small manual script to control this and
basically what we did is we leveraged
the fact that there's also a relay class
we connected it we said on which port
where were connected to so we connected
to normally open which means by default
the switch is open and then we just
close them immediately and injected the
whole thing into the repple so that we
can control it and I hope the video
works so we ran grande open at like 5
a.m. we started editing at 8 p.m. and it
started running water it's a bit hard to
see we didn't put coffee in it because
we weren't sure yet if it works and we
didn't want to waste coffee and once it
once your trigger grinder closed it's
going to it's going to close again
alright um cool so once we were done
with that we just locked up the whole
thing um closed it again properly put
the sides back on and use the fact that
now that we remove the buttons we had
some holes there so we just wired the
cable through it put a button on it
that's the Johnny Five logo and then
wires the whole stuff on top so that in
theory we could even unplug the cables
here now and plug back in the control
plate and we could use the coffee
machine as intended without having
broken it because we didn't solder
anything but we still don't have an i/o
tea coffee machine wrap we were able to
control this with JavaScript but we
aren't able to have something that's
connected to the internet yet and this
is where my favourite status code comes
in for 18 I'm a teapot I don't know if
you've heard of this before this is a
suggested HTTP status code it's not an
official one but some people use it so
if you go to google.com slash
teapot it actually returns that HTTP
status code um and it was suggested in
the IETF RFC to 3 to 4 which is the HTC
CP or in other words the hypertext
coffeepot control protocol which was
suggested on April 1st 1998 and this
gives you an idea why we actually hacked
our coffee machine last weekend because
we're approaching April 1st and we
figure it is a good point to to
implement this protocol so we took this
protocol actually and implemented it or
parts of it but I first want to give you
an overview of it so it's it's based on
top of HTTP so you can use gaps and post
like there used to you can also use the
new method brew it's not limited to
copper to the coffee protocol though
either just in case you want to derive a
beer brewing protocol the RFC suggests
you could use the same method it suggest
you use a safe header to recommend
whether you can do the same operation
again so you can use this with
conditionals as well like if user is
awake you can't through another coffee
and it adds a new except additions
headers so you can add milk or serve or
alcohol to your coffee
it suggests the HTTP status code for 18
in case you try to talk to a copy to a
teapot rather than a coffee pot with
your instructions and obviously we need
to be able to address them so it defines
a URI scheme as well and many more
things this is actually the definition
of the except additions header fields so
with milk type syrup type sweetener type
spice type and alcohol type on sweetener
and spice type are not defined as what
is limited to that's probably great for
Starbucks so they can still use this if
they want to do pumpkin spice lattes um
but yeah that's basically what they
recommend
this is a coffee your eye scheme and I'm
happy that the screen is so big because
my favorite part is this so that's the
German one and you can see it starts
with like in person for be the reason I
cut it actually out is written below is
that they're internationalized and it
insists on that you use a capital K for
coffee if you're using the German
protocol so you need to escape that by
using person for B and then we have a
pod integer
you can add additions to it the great
thing is it's a life we actually have
something working and I'm going to do a
demo so I'm going to switch to my lovely
coffee machine here I couldn't bring my
actual coffee machine because my flat
net would have been really mad
especially if I wouldn't have gotten
this talking so I brought this coffee
machine here it's a fake coffee machine
it's basically a bunch of LEDs that
somebody will simulate the three buttons
that we would press so you can see that
the button of the fake buttons are
pressed and then we have the script here
and we have the script running or any is
basically an HTTP server so there's
nothing Hardware specific in this script
I'm using local tunnel to create an
address that we can externally at access
and basically once we have that all set
up we set up the coffee machine and when
that is ready we can use it and then we
just handle the request so what you can
see we check if the coffee machine is
actually a teapot just in case
we've get methods that respond with the
appropriate coffee message coffee pot
content type which is one that is
suggested in the protocol we also have
post and brew I don't think the HTTP
from node supports grew but I didn't try
that yet we set the headers armed and
yeah we check for all this stuff like
the correct content type we check for
the accept additions unfortunately our
coffee machine doesn't support any
additions yet but it will come and yeah
so let's do a quick demo I'm going to
make this a bit bigger so I have my
authorization here it talks about
security in the RFC but I wasn't really
sure what they weren't really specific
what's the best authorization is so I
just have like I created my own header
and then we specify the content type so
I'm going to do a get actually to pot 0
so that should tell us if the internet
isn't too slow like local tunnel is
sometimes a bit slow there we go
currently the coffee machine is on
that's great now I had to improvise with
the URI scheme a bit because it doesn't
suggest like it's a copy pod
supports multiple versions or copies
which at not in 1998 wasn't really
common so I extended the thing a bit so
we can order an espresso and now you
should look at the LEDs so I'm going to
do a post request to the LEDs I'm going
to specify start and there we go the LED
lit up and the same port run there we
have the problem that right now we
aren't able to measure whether the
status is the right one like whether
it's currently brewing a coffee or not
we could figure this out by checking
what the value on the LEDs are on the
respective ones that we have on the
original board but the problem there is
that we would literally like the current
solution that we could only come up with
is having a photo sensor measure whether
literally the LED is on because we don't
share a common ground between the tehsil
and coffee machine so we can't measure
the values if you want to know more
about that we can talk about that later
over coffee and yeah so we can also turn
this whole thing off so that should
trigger the other one boom so that all
worked let's quickly look at the actual
coffee code so what we do is we similar
to the manual script we just initialize
the different relays that we're
connected to and then we have a press
power method which just checks if it's
on which currently is just a fake
because I know it's like it takes 20
seconds roughly to heat up so I'm
waiting for 21 seconds until it's on and
then we have a switch method and all of
them call this press baton method which
in order to simulate a button press we
just open the relay wait for 500
milliseconds and then close it again the
reason for that is if we would just keep
it open it would just continue running
until we close it again but if we only
present shortly starts brewing only the
amount that we need so for a Nespresso
would only brew that much rather than
having to figure out how many seconds it
takes to brew a copy we let that be done
by the coffee machine itself and that's
all like that's literally all the code
that we need
so let me switch back to my slides all
right so what did what what did we
actually learn during this during this
hack um first of all reverse engineering
is a lot of fun trying to figure this
out it's it's way too addicting I think
we started at 7 or 8 p.m. on on Friday
and we stayed up until 6 a.m. or
something until we finally had coffee
which was useful at that time because
like we totally didn't want to go to
sleep but it was real really a lot of
fun because reverse engineering an API
or something is already interesting but
reverse engineering something where you
have even less of a clue that's even
better
it can be very very frustrating though
because you can't just like it's harder
to reverse engineer hardware than it is
to reverse engineer software especially
because it's easier to break things and
if you're doing this in the middle of
the night and you're burning something
you might not be able to get replacement
parts JavaScript and hardware work great
so this was the first time I actually
did a hack with any hope like the
different options that we had there I
have them lying around but I never had a
good news case for it and I think this
was a really good use days the tehsil 2
is great like it's so much fun to work
with it it has a great CLI on that you
can spin a you can easily configure the
Tesla you can run scripts on it you can
port them on it it works really well and
johnny-five is super useful because it
allows you to do this cross cross
hardware compatibility so that you can
move this over to a different platform
later if you want to use a different
microcontroller so what's next
we need to programmatically determine
the state of the coffee machine which as
I mentioned before is a bit tricky right
now and we need to add more relate so we
can finally like add milk to our coffee
we need an Alexa integration so we have
the API now but I figured that I've
finished that on Wednesday or something
I didn't have
to finish up the the rest of the
integration so we need an Alexa
integration or at least an if this then
that Handler and probably a Twilio
integration so I can text when I'm
walking home to brew your coffee and
then if you have any suggestions I'm
more than open to to hear any of your
suggestions give any real cool idea like
we need
we definitely need an Irish coffee
option so we need to figure out some way
how we can pour whiskey into it since
the accept additions headers of suggest
already that with whiskey as an option
and yeah with that thanks everyone my
name is Dominic if I not hack coffee
machines at work as a developer
evangelist for Twilio and if you have
any questions you can grab me later for
a coffee beer or shoot me a message
I think we have like a minute left or
something there's a question yet yes so
right that's exactly that's that's like
v4 we first need to be able to brew all
this stuff right now the the agreement
that we have is whoever takes the coffee
puts a new cup underneath it and puts a
new because it's an espresso so you need
to put this thing in it so you need to
put that in and put the cup back onto it
but you can do that in the evening or
whenever you took the last coffee and
it's ready so that when you wake up or
when you really feel like your coffee
but you don't feel like making your
coffee you you don't have to worry about
that anymore
any other questions all right thanks for
your attention
also if you want to see the hardware you
can drop by now or later or something I
can show you the stuff yeah